und wir kommen zum prozess des tages
dann stellen sie sich mal vor sie öffnen
bei ihrem nachbarn das garagentor und da
steht ein nazi panzer klaus-dieter 11
ein millionär hatte genauso einen panzer
aus dem zweiten weltkrieg weil sich im
keller und dafür steht da jetzt vor
gericht die staatsanwaltschaft wirft ihm
verstöße gegen das
kriegswaffenkontrollgesetz vor
ja denn bei dem rentner fand man ihn im
kieler vorort heikendorf auch noch
folgende sachen einen flugabwehrkanonen
ein torpedo einen mörser maschinen und
sturmgewehre munition hitler figur und
hakenkreuz fähnchen das ist wirklich
unglaublich ich habe mich heute morgen
gefragt was das für ein kranker typ sein
muss und unser kollege dino schröder
der hat den ersten tag heute im gericht
begleitet und kann uns sagen was hat der
angeklagte gesagt und vor allem wird er
gewirkt da über diese treppe hier im
kieler landgericht gegen der angeklagte
gestützt von seinem verteidiger zu dem
saal 232 im kieler landgericht dort kam
es dann zur anklage der angeklagte hat
sich aber heute noch gar nicht zu den
vorwürfen geäußert er wirkte aber
relativ ruhig und gelassen wechselt in
den einen oder anderen satz mit seinem
verteidiger
sag uns was genau droht ihnen jetzt im
schlimmsten fall ja also es ist so dass
die schlüsselfrage barnes kriegswaffen
oder nicht gab es diesen panzer torpedo
und flac darüber streiten sich
wahrscheinlich selbst die
sachverständigen die anklage sagt es
sind kriegswaffen dann gibt es
mindestens ein jahr gefängnis
wahrscheinlich dann auch zur bewährung
war es hat es nur einen musealen
charakter fällt die strafe wäre es nicht
nicht sogar aus die das ist die
schlüsselfrage und da gibt es auch zum
beispiel um panzer und da sagte wirklich
der verteidiger da ging es um das
lebenswerk seines mandanten
tatsächlich waren in verständigung
gesprächen zwischen staatsanwaltschaft
und verteidigung bei diesem panzer kam
es auf das man doch diesen plan
in die usa in ein militärmuseum nach
seattle bringen könnte die erlöse würden
sondern quasi teilen eine million euro
sollten dann in die staatskasse fließen
und die nur der bürgermeister der hat ja
kurzen nachdem das alles bekannt
geworden ist erzählt dass sozusagen der
angeklagte dabei sich im keller den
führerbunker nachgebaut hat da war auch
die rede davon dass dort ss-uniform
hakenkreuz fähnchen und so weiter
gefunden wurden spielt das vor gericht
eine rolle oder geht es eben wirklich
nur in anführungsstrichen um die waffen
tatsächlich geht es wirklich nur um die
waffen auch die anderen sachen sie ja
noch auftauchten was da sonst gemacht
haben soll in seinem garten mit
wehrsportgruppe das ist alles
garantieren es gibt wirklich nur in
diesem fall um das
kriegswaffenkontrollgesetz
denn der besitz von hakenkreuzfahnen
ähnlichen in privaten im keller
das ist nicht strafbar aber erst wenn
man so eine nazi fahne ist dann macht
man sich strafbar aber wie gesagt dass
es auch gar nicht bestandteil dieses
prozesses und jetzt wird auch wieder
versucht indem verständigung gesprächen
zu einem vielleicht vorzeitigen ende zu
kommen
vielen dank dino schröder für diese
erkenntnisse also aus dem ersten
prozesstag bei diesem wirklich sehr
irren prozess den wir hier sehen
danke mehr nachrichten und breaking news
nur bei bet schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren